[Música]
bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
hoy nos acompaña pedro calzadilla
presidente del consejo nacional
electoral de venezuela
muchas gracias por recibirnos quería
comenzar preguntándole después de varios
años se va a unas elecciones en
venezuela con una nueva directiva del
consejo nacional electoral que está
haciendo la nueva directiva
para recuperar la confianza no sólo en
el voto sino en la institución ya que
era visto como un ente afín al gobierno
que está actualmente en la
administración y mira bueno nada consejo
nuevo nuevo consejo nacional electoral
está designado de hace seis meses lo
designó a la asamblea nacional
resulta una elección del año pasado de
diciembre
esta nueva configuración del consejo
nacional electoral expresa un momento
importante del país en que se han
abierto unos espacios de diálogo de
entendimiento de encuentro y de alguna
manera este consejo nacional electoral
diverso plural
expresión de todas las visiones y
perspectivas del país está
digamos reafirmando los principios que
están establecido en nuestra
constitución
y que signa que marca que indica
la línea de un poder aparte venezuela y
cinco poderes y quien y el ente que
organiza las elecciones es la cabeza de
uno de esos cinco poderes
bueno hemos desplegado en este tiempo de
estos seis meses la primera gran tarea
que tenemos es la organización de las
elecciones del próximo 21 de noviembre y
ahí hemos estado trabajando de manera
armonizada
sincronizada de manera unánime todos los
todos los rectores los cinco rectores
principales y los tres suplentes
incorporados
como siempre reiterando reafirmando
todas las garantías que nos corresponde
darle a los ciudadanos ciudadanas para
que
reafirmen nuevamente en las elecciones
un talante democrático que se ha
sostenido en venezuela hace muchos años
como influyó o si influyó de alguna
manera el diálogo entre oposición y
gobierno en méxico para la escogencia de
esta nueva que tiene ya seis meses junta
del consejo nacional electoral hubo
exigencias o condiciones para está para
elegir la sí fíjate una cosa del
el proceso de diálogo tiene mucho tiempo
y con actores distintos y desde hace ya
algunos años
quizás sea este año donde se han visto
como resultados tangibles el año pasado
también la elección de la asamblea
nacional
méxico ha sido uno de esos de esas
expresiones de ese diálogo es muy
importante y que abrió digamos el abrió
un nuevo nivel de esos espacios de
diálogo
no son exigencias pero si ha habido como
se ha puesto en el tapete el tema
electoral que es justamente el espacio
de credibilidad del ts dónde se
legitiman los poderes el espacio donde
se ejerce la soberanía popular dónde se
manifiesta entonces bueno es justamente
reiterando que es el consejo nacional
electoral actual hijo criatura de los
espacios de diálogo entre ellos el de
méxico que fue posterior por cierto a la
insta a la designación del consejo
nacional electoral pero todos los
actores políticos todos todos así como
están participando en las elecciones
actuales en venezuela todos los actores
participaron en eso en esos encuentros
en esas conversaciones que dieron
nacimiento a este consejo nacional
electoral
como fue recibido por distintos sectores
políticos del país en la invitación que
se le hizo a la observación
internacional a la digamos a la misión
de la unión europea porque he leído un
poco que tantos sectores de la oposición
como algunos afines al gobierno tuvieron
como un cierto rechazo
sí bueno una de las de los asuntos que
justamente está en el ánimo nuestro que
me preguntabas qué cosas se han hecho
para ofrecer todavía más garantías a los
electores y las electoras uno de esos
temas es cometer la observación
internacional la veeduría internacional
el acompañamiento internacional
para estas elecciones que son regionales
y municipales
que por lo general no concitan tanto
interés a nivel internacional por lo que
significa en el marco del proceso
actualmente político en venezuela lo
relevante lo importante de este proceso
entonces ha suscitado interés y nosotros
le hemos puesto todo el interés de que
vengan personas y organizaciones de
fuera
desde muy temprano que usamos
invitaciones ya están ya están una buena
parte de bien venezuela cerca de 300
personas de otras partes del mundo van a
estar en estos días la unión europea es
uno de ellos el centro carter el sela el
consejo de expertos electorales
latinoamericanos
el observatorio del parlasur
cómo se llaman las naciones unidas un
panel de expertos
todos ellos tienen van a tener presencia
y hay
desde posiciones distintas
extremas quizás
digamos
posiciones de rechazo a la participación
de ciertos algunos y determinados
actores internacionales nosotros hemos
reiterado nosotros hemos hecho una hemos
puesto muy clara las cosas de hecho han
surgido algunas discrepancias con
los jefes algunos de los jefes y
autoridades de la unión europea
las declaraciones de volver por ejemplo
fueron un punto que puso en riesgo todo
el esfuerzo que habíamos hecho pero eso
se subsanó cuando se reafirmó que ellos
vendrían aquí bajo las pautas de un
acuerdo administrativo que firmamos que
establece muy bien la no injerencia la
reconocimiento del poder electoral el
reconocimiento del orden constitucional
y legal en venezuela ahí están las
pautas y una vez que estemos apegados
ahí no hay problemas son bienvenidos y
yo lo que invito yo lo que hago es
generar lo que invito es que tengamos
confianza en que todo esto va a sumar a
una buena un buen resultado las próximas
elecciones a eso iba paso más de una
década que no se invitaban como estos
organismos internacionales porque acá
vieran siempre veedores no la última los
últimos 13 años ahora sí vienen estos
organismos que normalmente se reconocen
internacionalmente como observadores que
pasó que cambió que volvieron de nuevo
al país mira
debo decirte que si el año pasado
el consejo nacional electoral invitó a
la unión europea
eran circunstancias políticas han
variado las circunstancias políticas no
las condiciones
técnicas las condiciones del poder
electoral ni las invitaciones
qué ocurre porque interesa venir ahora
porque esta elección está en la agenda
de trabajo de estos espacios de diálogo
está en el interés no sólo de una
elección regional municipal sino una
elección que tiene
digamos un papel que cumplir en el
proceso de estabilización del país de
estabilidad política y de la
reafirmación de la paz del país por eso
es la la diferencia y se ha hecho algún
tipo de pacto no sé si entre los actores
opositores y los actores afines al
gobierno que participan en esta elección
para que respeten el informe que pueden
emitir estos observadores
internacionales que han vuelto al país
bueno es importante saber que ellos van
a emitir un informe donde hacen
recomendaciones dan opiniones
evaluarán cosas por superar escollo y yo
supongo y que hago estoy confiado que
van a reconocer también las virtudes de
nuestro sistema electoral y del ambiente
político también en venezuela que ha ido
avanzando positivamente
este
bueno yo creo que los actores políticos
tienen la libertad de
leer esos informes
según sus propios criterios
por supuesto eso son opiniones nunca va
a interferir en la opinión digamos
lo que diga el árbitro electoral que
somos nosotros a la hora de decir qué
pasó el 21 de noviembre cuáles son los
resultados etcétera pero sin duda son
opiniones valiosas que nosotros vamos
sin duda a considerar a leer a leer a
evaluar ponderar y
emitiremos comentarios sobre lo que
estos organismos internacionales que son
varios muchos alrededor de 10 total de
mito qué significado tiene que la
oposición vuelva de nuevo a
el proceso electoral o sea que ellos
hayan decidido participar después que
han llamado a las últimas tres
elecciones a la extensión así que
significa mucho significa mucho por el
pedido esperanzador yo debo decirte que
hay
87 partidos políticos participando en
estas elecciones es una cifra importante
entre partidos nacionales regionales y
partidos indígenas
todos los partidos políticos todos
han postulado candidatos incluso
partidos políticos cuyos algunos
dirigentes han manifestado que no están
de acuerdo con las elecciones es decir
lo que te quiero decir es que
hacía mucho tiempo que no había una tan
alta concurrencia de los partidos lo que
le da legitimidad y mucho crédito a este
proceso nosotros celebramos eso de
manera importante y para el país yo creo
que es muy valioso y hemos tratado de
cuidar que todos los pastores políticos
concurran y que reconozcan a la
autoridad electoral
quizás con críticas algunos poco más
profundas o no pero al final
reconociendo que tenemos un sistema que
permite barajar nuevamente la
los equilibrios del poder en los
municipios y las regiones ok muchas
gracias por recibirnos
hasta aquí la entrevista de france 24
para sintonizarlas nuevamente recuerden
visitar nuestro sitio web france24
puntocom hasta la próxima